[Music]
hey guys
today I have a video about probably my
third favorite subject after beer and my
dog Oswald and that is squatting this
video reviews a new study that came out
called quadriceps effort during squat
exercise depends on hip extensor muscle
strategy and it is just as exciting as
it sounds it was a follow up to a 2012
study done by the same lead researcher
Megan Bryant --an and in the first study
what they did is they found the
participants maximum knee and hip
extension torque at various joint angles
and then had them work up to a 90
percent squat in increments of 10% so 50
60 70 80 90 % and then compared the
amount of torque that they would have to
produce at those joints to lift the
weight to the amount of torque that they
were capable of producing at those
joints and the resultant number was
termed relative muscular effort and that
was the minimum amount of torque
necessary to lift the weight relative to
what they were capable of and one of the
surprising findings in that study is
that even with 90 % loads at the bottom
of a squat the most challenging part for
your quads the relative muscular effort
was only about 60% and that's kind of a
puzzling finding because obviously a 90
% squat probably represents more than a
60% effort from the quads and so in this
follow-up study basically what they were
trying to do was model hamstrings
co-contraction
so the first study was looking at the
minimum amount of work the quads would
have to do to extend the knees but in
the real world they're never going to
only be doing the minimum amount of work
they would have to do because the
hamstrings will also be contracting to
extend the hips
but as they contract that resists knee
extension there they insert on the
opposite side
the joint from the quad so as the quads
are trying to extend the knees as the
hamstrings are contracting to extend the
hips that's resisting the knee extension
that the quads are that the quads are
doing so they developed two models the
first model assumed that the glutes and
hamstrings shared the load equally so if
they had to produce 80% of maximum hip
extension torque the glutes were
contracting 80% as hard as they could
and the hamstrings 80% as hard as they
could the second model assumed that the
glutes did everything they possibly
could before the hamstrings did anything
so for that same 80% contraction the
glutes who are already contracting 100%
as hard as they possibly could and the
hamstrings to make up the rest would be
50 60 % contraction and so these would
represent basically the upper and lower
bounds of how hard the hamstrings could
be working in the squat model 1 assuming
they contract equally that would be the
upper bound and model 2 assuming that
the glutes did everything they possibly
could before the hamstrings kicked in
would represent the lower bound so they
took the data from the first study and
ran it through these two models to look
and see how it would affect quadriceps
effort since the original study was only
looking at the minimum knee extension
that the minimum knee extension torque
that would have to be produced to lift
the load the second study wanted to look
and see how different hip extensor
strategies would affect the quadriceps
effort with model 1 being kind of the
most challenging you could expect it to
be for the quads and model 2 being the
least challenging you would expect it to
be for the quads so here you can see the
data that they got from the two models
the black line you see there is the data
from the original study just looking at
the external torque that would be the
minnow
amount of net me extension torque that
needed to be produced to lift the weight
so that's not taking into account
hamstrings co-contraction at all the red
line is model one that's the one that
assumed that hamstring and glute
contraction increased at the same rate
so you know for every X amount of glute
contraction you got X amount of
hamstring contraction the the same
amount relative to maximum and the Green
Line is model to assuming that the
glutes would do everything they possibly
could to create hip extension twerk
before the hamstrings kicked in as well
and so what you can see is that green
line it's it's considerably higher than
the black line the minimum amount but
they're all the way to the right side of
the graph at the bottom of the squat
knee flexion angles above a hundred and
five degrees the peak it reaches is
eighty seven percent of the maximum
amount of force the quads could produce
so this is a 90 percent squat so eighty
seven percent of the maximum amount of
work the quads could do that's pretty
darn close to what you'd expect the red
line on the other hand assuming
equivalent amount of glute and hamstring
action to produce the required hip
extension to work you see there at the
bottom of the squat it goes all the way
up to a hundred and twenty percent
basically showing that if that model was
true or close to how reality actually
works the the quads would have to be
essentially a fifth stronger than they
actually are twenty percent stronger
than they actually are
to create the knee extension torque
required to to lift the weight to get
the weight moving out of the hole so
basically what we can take from this is
that model to the one assumed
that basically the the hamstrings we're
doing as little as they possibly could
and the glutes doing as much as they
possibly could to create the required
hip extension to work is probably pretty
close to how the squat actually works in
reality and that kind of makes sense if
you think about it intuitively because
basically the quads specifically the the
vast eye excluding the rectus femoris
since it's actually a hip flexor but the
other three quad muscles and the glutes
they're single joint muscles they the
quads create knee extension torque and
the glutes create hip extension to work
without really screwing with the other
joint very much whereas the hamstrings
while they are powerful hip extension
extensors they also resist the quads
because they create a knee flexion
torque basically resisting what the
quads are trying to do so it kind of
makes sense that your central nervous
system wouldn't activate them more than
more than it actually had to to create
the required hip extension torque to
complete the movement because the more
active they are at the harder the
movement becomes for your quads so what
do we do with all of this there are two
major takeaways the first is that you
shouldn't really be trying to prioritize
your hamstrings in the squat the squat
is is a pretty crummy hamstrings
exercise anyways it's it's very
overrated in that regard I've written
about that a fair amount in the past and
articles will be linked in the
description of this video going into
that in more detail but if you try to
squat in a manner that maximizes
hamstrings involvement sitting back more
and leaning forward quite a bit more
what that's actually going to do is it's
going to make the movement quite a bit
harder for your quads coming out of the
hole while also again sitting back more
increasing hip extension demands so
there's really no upside that you get
from that
the second big implication is that if
you do have issues coming out of the
hole in the squat if you if your butt
shoots up and you wind up in more of a
good morning position something that can
help with that is obviously
strengthening your quads so they can do
more of the work but a secondary thing
would be to work on strengthening your
glutes because essentially the the more
they can do the less your hamstrings
have to do it kicks it pushes back to
the point that your hamstrings are
having to contract harder and harder and
harder to produce the required hip
extension torque so if you are finding
yourself in a good morning squat
position and you do have strong quads
the next place you should look to
rectify that would be your glutes if
they're not very strong then even if you
do have strong quads you could still be
finding yourself in that position all
right guys that's about it for this
video this this video was a somewhat
abbreviated version of an article I
recently wrote for my website to string
theory calm that will be linked in the
description along with the study that I
was reviewing and so if this is a topic
that interests you or if I said
something that that didn't sound quite
right rest assured that I probably went
into that subject and quite a bit more
depth in the article itself so go ahead
and check that out if this is if this is
a subject that interests you and other
than that thanks for watching please
like and subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video